right-hander kyle gibson's going for the
texas rangers last couple of outings
against the detroit tigers he's gotten
roughed up a little bit
yanks that one
four pitch walk to start this game
the astros who struggle for base runners
against gibson at times
get a free pass to start this one on
four pitches
inside ball four
back-to-back walks to start this game he
has not walked more than two astros at
any of his three previous starts this
year he's a pretty good poker face but
he's obviously
fighting
to find his command with every pitch it
seems
upstairs ball four four pitch walk
he's had a four pitch walk up five pitch
walk and now another four pitch walk
and the astros leader in walks will come
to the plate in carlos correa three
walks in a 3-1 count
[Applause]
ball four bases loaded walk
astros lead one to nothing
season high four walks issued by kyle
gibson
only five batters into this game
they threw a 3-1 change up to carlos
that tells you a lot yeah getting off
that fastball not a lot of confidence in
that fastball we saw a slider get over
in that at-bat against carlos correa
lucky enough to be in the right place at
the right time been fooling him ever
since
another walk issued by kyle gibson
second walk to michael brantley fifth
walk i said mr scully thank you so much
he says if you don't call me vin we'll
never speak
hits one down the again and left michael
brantley on the move to third julie is
gonna get to second astros in business
second and third
nobody out alvarez with 61 rbis that
leads the team
first pitch swings hits it into right
center shallow coming in for it's white
he's got it tagging at third is brantley
here's the play safe
in and out of the glove of trevino and
over to third base goes guriel astros
lead 2-nothing on the rbi sacrifice fly
by jordan alvarez
maybe got that in enough on on jordan
that he couldn't really drive it
and yeah i was wondering whether
brantley would test white there
and it paid off and then to compound
things trevino couldn't handle the one
hop throw
mr correa's driven to right field pretty
deep eli white's got it tagging his
guriel racing home and it's late
sacrifice fly for correa the astros lead
three to nothing
that was definitely deep enough
and the ball getting away from trevino
when
brantley scored allowing guriel to get
to third
yeah i thought last year was a big step
in that maturation process we saw him
really start to enjoy himself and loosen
up a little bit on the mound the one
thing about frohmer is carlos correa
makes a nice play to get charlie
culbertson on that bouncer up the middle
for the first out
fromer never gets phased by runners on
base
ground ball towards the hole correa
knocks it down recovers strong throw in
time
the man should have won a gold glove
last year and he's vying for another one
this year he knows that defense is going
to play well behind him that is a tough
play on the backhand but there was no
panic from carlos correa
it's because he knows he's got a cannon
in his right arm
and how about julie picking him up
there's good team defense right there
started by carlos correa showing some
range
ground ball slowly hit towards toro on
two hops his off balance throw
in time that's a six pitch inning for
fromber with three ground ball outs
we're halfway home afros lead this game
three to nothing
michael brantley at this stage in his
career
his age has to play a ton of outfield
and he's on his feet a bunch
which is one thing that would be maybe a
little bit concerning
this ball hit out to center field drops
in that's a base hit guriel
turns for third and he gets there now
he's headed to the plate here comes a
relay throw got him
not sure what happened with guriel there
was a moment in the outfield
or maybe he sensed an opportunity
because garcia had a little trouble but
it ends the ending
both starting pitchers
walking six tonight matching their
career highs in a weird game
called third strike the curveball breaks
over robert valdez through six innings
all six base runners have been via walks
but he picks up a strikeout to end the
inning open up the back door and walk
right through it and he was pretty happy
about it
that is walk number eight
unbelievable that's enough for chris
woodward he's gonna have to go out and
get his all-star starter
who has dominated the astros the last
couple of years but tonight he will
leave with eight walks and a hit batter
in five and two-thirds innings
they ain't gonna let him go
i'm not sure yeah looks that way
convinced him to leave him in
2-2 pitch and a little bouncer up the
middle quick underhand to second the
inning is done and the astros leave them
loaded seventh inning on the way
six scoreless innings this day is done
three nothing astros as they turn it
over to the bullpen
swag in a minute he got him
uh brand-new with back-to-back
strikeouts to get through the seventh
seventh inning stretch time
astros lead this game three to nothing
jordan has walked
knocked in a run with a sacrifice fly
and singled rbi number 62 on the year
for jordan as he hits one high and deep
to right field is it enough yes it is
home run number 18 on the season
astros now lead four to nothing
that might be one of the few ones that
we haven't seen go 400 plus feet this is
97 in on the hands
and he gets enough of it
that's some grown man strength right
there forcing that one out of here
he's allowed six home runs on his
fastball this year
there is a fast ball and that one hit
out to right field and it is going to
drop in
that was trapped and that's a base hit
and kinder felefa gets that first
rangers hit of the night
and will not be no hit tonight
rangers are looking for somebody to step
up 3-2
and that ball hit well
deep out to left and that one is gone
the bagnes mashed that one
a towering homer up to the railroad
tracks
and the rangers will not be shut out
tonight second career homer for
abanez and it's 4-1
call third strike astros are winners
4-1 the final score
astros match their season high 21 games
over 500.